Hi there.
My name is Katherine Kuan
and I'm a developer advocate
on the Google Developer
Relations team.
I'm here today with
a gift idea for you
for this upcoming
Valentine's Day,
or that next special occasion
that's around the corner.
The idea is that you
can create a mobile app
for your special someone.
So you can go run and tell
them, I made this just for us.
In today's fast
paced world, you can
buy the most extravagant present
with the click of a button.
But sometimes, the
most meaningful things
are the things you
can't buy off a shelf.
They are the things that you
can create yourself and add
a personal touch to.
Because, after
all, you're the one
who knows your loved one best
and how to melt their heart.
You'll download the
source code for the app,
customize it, and then give it
as a gift to your Valentine.
Now keep in mind that
it could be for any one
important in your life-- your
significant other, parent, best
friend, et cetera.
So let's walk through the app.
It contains a list of coupons
where each one can be redeemed
for a favor or some
event to do together.
For example, you can
have a coupon to wake
up insanely early and go
watch a sunrise together.
You could have a coupon
for a getaway to Hawaii
or a picnic at a vineyard.
These are just some examples.
The only rule is to be as
creative as you can be.
Whenever the person is
ready to redeem the coupon,
they'll click on it and the
Share dialog will pop up.
They can pick
which app they want
to use to contact
you to redeem it.
There will be a pre-populated
message and photo
from the coupon so that
you can just hit send.
Then it's up to you to fulfill
your end of the bargain.
If they want a more public way
of declaring how lucky they are
to have such a thoughtful
person like you in their life,
then they can share to
G+ or other apps as well.
Let's get into the steps of
how to customize the app.
First, you can create
a custom app icon.
Roman Nurik, who is a fellow
developer advocate on the team,
created this custom
tool where you
can insert a photo of you and
your Valentine into this heart.
It will generate the icon of
you at all the right densities.
When you open up the tool,
you'll see a blank heart.
Then, upload your image of your
choice, either a picture of you
two, or the picture
of an adorable puppy.
You can adjust the scaling
and padding in the image
as well so it'll look centered.
Once you create
your app icon, you
can download the zip file of
the icons and save it for later.
Now you'll want to download
the code for the app.
You'll need Android
Studio to open the app.
If you haven't
installed it before,
see the link for how to
set up Android Studio.
Once you're looking
at the code, you
should fill in the sender
name with your name.
That way, when the coupon
is shared to another app,
the sentence will
contain your name too.
Like in this example, I'm
excited to redeem my coupon
with Amy.
Just to add a
personal touch to it.
Next you'll want to add
photos for your own coupons
in the assets folder where
the other images are located.
Here's a screenshot of what
the assets folder looks
like in Android studio.
Now you can just add the lines
of code to create the coupons.
Specify a title,
description, and the name
of the corresponding image
file in the assets folder.
After you're done
customizing it,
you can give it your Valentine.
You can use Google Play to
make it available to them.
Optionally, you can restrict
the app availability
using the alpha channel
feature in Google Play.
We've given you the basics,
but you can extend it further.
Think of new ways you
can bond with this person
by taking advantage of
what a phone can offer.
Your phone can buzz when another
person is thinking of you.
If you hook it up
to a web service,
you can send them little notes
or pictures to their device.
So start brainstorming,
and be the first one
to build a personal
app for your loved one.
That should earn you some
major brownie points.
You can share
screenshots of the app
that you've built with
the hashtag #justforus
and it will give other people
ideas on what to do too.
Thanks for watching, and I can't
wait to see what you build.